Well,
we actually have it in Sweden.
It's called the,
I think the translation is
and gender mainstreaming in,
in English,
but it's basically you have to include
gender scientific perspectives into all
this is happening within all
Swedish universities right now.
Uh,
so you have to include
the perspective of gender,
gender,
scientific perspective,
all parts of the university.
So it's not just literature
lists of courses,
it's also the who are
you going to recruit?
Uh,
the number,
and we have a goal in Sweden and,
uh,
from the government.
This is all the government's doing.
MMM.
We have a goal that I think
it's 40% of all the professors,
uh,
by 2020 should be women.
Right.
Which means that if you're a
young man who's entering academia,
the probability that you're
going to get to job zero.
Yeah.
Right.
And that,
yeah,
the same thing's happening here.
So for example,
this,
there,
our minister of science,
who was one of the people,
let's say,
selected because of Trudeau's insistence
upon gender equity in his cabinet.
Um,
you know,
he could have picked a number of women
that was proportionate to the number of
women elected.
Like even that I wouldn't have agreed
with because I think he should've gone on
straight competence and,
and,
and taken on the heavy moral burden of
trying to figure out what competence
meant but just,
but no,
it had to be 50,
50,
because I guess that was,
you know,
this is a very snide thing to say,
but that seems to be at the level of
arithmetic intelligence that he could
manifest.
You know,
it's,
and,
and one of his ministers,
our Minister of science has,
we have this program called camp.
The Canada research chairs and the Canada
research chairs were set up so that
Canadian universities would
have an additional amount
of money to hire the most
qualified people they possibly could
for senior named chair positions.
And the idea was to attract
international talent,
like high level.
Now what has happened,
because it wasn't very well designed,
this program was that
Canadian universities mostly
ended up poaching from each
other,
which was,
you know,
relatively counterproductive because
it just elevated the salaries of the
professors,
which maybe they deserve rather than
bringing in a lot of international talent.
But man,
we're radically overrepresented
in Canada research chairs now.
The Minister of science is very annoyed
about this and thinks that that's a
consequence of systemic.
Yeah.
You know,
misogyny or some some bloody thing.
Failing to note entirely.
See,
if you look at scientific productivity,
it's very interesting because and gender,
the median professor male and
publish approximately the same amount.
So the typical,
but the,
the exceptional professors
are almost all men.
Even though the typical male and
female can't really be distinguished in
academia.
If you'd take that tiny subset
of hyper productive professors,
they're almost all male.
Now why that is is my suspicions are
that it's pretty straight forward.
I suspect that the reason it is is because
to be a hyper productive in any given
field means you have to be absolutely
single minded and obsessed about it as
well as being very intelligent,
conscientious.
So it's rare,
right?
You have to be intelligent,
say 99th percentile conscientious,
95th percentile.
So that's hard.
The anybody right there.
And then you have to have the time
available to do nothing whatsoever,
but concentrate on your work.
No family,
no friends,
nothing like that.
If you're going to be at the very top
of your profession because obviously
you'll get out competed otherwise.
Now that's a lot harder for women because,
well,
for obvious reasons,
I mean so,
so the mere fact that
most of these people were,
see the other thing people
don't understand is that
people can on average be
very similar.
So their distributions,
but if you go way out on to
the edges of the distribution,
small differences in the middle can
make massive differences at the edge.
And so,
and that's the kind of phenomena you
see where you are selecting the highest
qualified people.
It's a,
it's an edge of the
distribution phenomena.
So here's an example.
This is really cool one.
So if you look at the overlap
between male and female aggression,
it's pretty high.
So if you randomly select a man and
a woman from the general population,
and you bet that the woman was
the more aggressive of the two,
you'd be right 40% of the time,
which is actually pretty often.
So,
but if you go way the hell out to where,
let's say you only imprisoned the
one in 100 most aggressive people,
they're all men.
Even though on average it's 60 40
you'd go out to the 99th percentile.
It's all men,
which is why almost all the
people in prison are men now.
So people,
well it's,
it's,
yeah.
What you're describing in Sweden,
that's the death of the universities.
It's another,
it's another sign of like,
the universities are killing themselves.
They're hiring adjunct professors
and not faculty members.
Like I think it's up to 70%
in some American universities.
They have no salary,
no power,
no autonomy,
no job security,
nothing.
It's,
it's,
you know,
some of these adjuncts teach four or
five courses a year and make $25,000.
So it's,
I read about one who lived in her car.
Yeah.
Okay.
So they've jacked up tuition,
but you honorary proletariat.
Yeah,
exactly.
Well,
there you go.
You know,
um,
they've jacked up too.
They've jacked up tuition to the
point where it's unsustainable.
They've made it impossible for kids
who rack up tuition debt to declare
bankruptcy because they've taken
that out of the bankruptcy laws.
Now you can take away their driver's
license if they don't pay their,
their,
uh,
their tuition,
their student loan bills.
So it's basically indentured servitude,
right?
The administration has
become completely top heavy.
The academy is completely infested by
these terrible equity ideas that you're
laying out.
I mean,
it's,
and,
and the people who are in the
radical leftists disciplines,
which increasingly are spreading
their influence out through the entire
universities are tenured and
won't be moved for 25 years.
So as far as I can tell,
it's done.